SCORE.
ON THE LITTLE SPACE
WITH THE GOAL
OFFENSIVELY THEY WERE GOOD
AGAINST ARIZONA, THEY HAVE THAT
DEFENSIVE CHALLENGE, AND I
MANSON -- KIRILL KAPRIZOV,
THERE WAS NO CHANCE FOR JOST SCT
HIS FORMER
GAMES.
>> TODAY, MACKINNON, 24 CUT OFFY
FRANCOUZ OVER TO THE SIDE, JARED
SPURGEON.
PRESSURE NOT BY TYSON JOST. IT E
>> 40 GAMES, 77 NIGHTS IN THE
SEAS SOMETHING
GO.
>> IN T T GERARD, RENTON AND
TRYING TO CENTER.
AND HE JOST.
THE FIGHT BETWEEN THE BURAKOVSK,
GERARD, THAT WOULD CLINCH HOME E
FOR.
>> SPURGEON WALKING THEIG CHANC.
AND SPURGEON MOVES THROUGH
RYAN HARTMAN AND THEN DOING
ANYTHING TO DIRECT IT T SCORES,
BEATING MARC-ANDRE FLEURY, THER.
FACE>> MINNESOTA AND THEIR LEADS
STILL SCORES.
6-FOOT 4 INCHES.
THAT WILL SEAL